NOKIA:
This is likely the most recognizable ringtone
of all time, the nostalgic anthem of the early
2000s signifying the transition into the new
mobile world.
It was a time when Nokia was the most dominant
cellphone manufacturer in the world.
They controlled over 50% of the entire global
mobile market selling over 100 million phones
every single year.
This not only made them a mobile giant but
a corporate giant with a peak market cap of
nearly $300 billion.
But since then, it has only been bad news
for Nokia.
As smartphones entered the market, Nokia’s
annual sales fell off a cliff down to less
than 20 million phones per year.
Their annual revenue collapsed even harder
as it crashed from $60 billion down to just
$6 billion.
In fact, during the worst of it, they were
losing $6 billion on an annual basis meaning
that their expenses were twice their revenue.
Microsoft would try coming to the rescue as
they bought out Nokia’s phone business for
$7.2 billion but not long after, Microsoft
would end up writing off the entire acquisition
price plus more as a complete loss.
And they would turn around and sell off the
remaining parts for just $350 million.
But, despite all of this, Nokia is somehow
still around.
In fact, they’re still worth just over $20
billion.
They’ve even reentered the phone market
after Microsoft left and they’re doing surprisingly
well.
Just last year, their smartphone sales tripled
as the Nokia C100 became the 15th best selling
smartphone in the US.
As such, they’ve been posting some of their
best quarters in last 15 years pulling in
nearly $5 billion per year.
Of course, this is still a far cry from their
once ubiquitous position in the market.
But, for a company that most would assume
went bankrupt year ago, Nokia is actually
doing quite well.
In fact, you could easily argue that Nokia
is super undervalued as their PE ratio currently
sits at a measly 5.
So, join me as we take a look at how Nokia
has managed to not just stick around but recover
in the era of smartphones.
THE FALL BEGINS:
Jumping straight into the beginning of the
downfall, we have Nokia’s apex year: 2007.
This was the fateful year that the iPhone
was announced, so it’s not surprising that
it was also the peak of Nokia but it wasn’t
all doom and gloom.
In fact, Nokia actually already had a foot
in the smartphone race before the iPhone.
In 2005, they released Linux based mobile
operating system called Maemo which they shipped
with their Nokia 770 tablet.
They were also relatively early to making
touch screen phones, the first of which they
launched in October 2008.
But while Nokia had the right overall idea,
they fell short from several aspects starting
with software.
For the longest time, Nokia was always known
for hardware.
They made some of the most durable and reliable
phones on the market.
In fact, people would often describe their
phones as being bricks but what Nokia didn’t
realize is that people were willing to sacrifice
durability for functionality.
Phones were rapidly evovling from being calling
devices to being small computers, something
that Nokia completely overlooked.
As such, instead of embracing Android and
coming out as the main competitor to the iPhone,
Nokia wasted their time making their own crappy
OS called Symbian.
Not only was Symbian clunky and lacking basic
functionality, but more importantly, it had
virtually no support from developers meaning
that users were more or less limited to the
in house apps.
But, it wasn’t just the software side of
things where Nokia was lacking.
Pretty soon, they were lacking on the hardware
side of things as well.
It seems that Nokia thought that hardware
just meant durability as they would neglect
upgrading the internal components and specs.
Just think about this.
Nokia was literally selling phones that didn’t
even have 3G capability while iPhones and
Androids had already moved onto 4g.
Yeah, it was really bad.
Speaking of Androids and iPhones, Nokia also
dropped the ball when it came to branding
their smartphones.
Apple and Samsung hit this out of the park
with the iPhone and Galaxy branding.
But, when it came to Nokia, there really was
no branding, I mean, just listen to these
names.
Nokia 5800 XpressMusic, Nokia 603, Nokia 701,
Nokia 808 PureView like what does 808 even
mean?
I have no idea and I think is how most consumers
felt as well.
Nokia probably felt that the Nokia name itself
was enough to appeal to customers which brings
us into our next pitfall: overconfidence.
Nokia largely overestimated the value of their
brand, and it’s not surprising why, they
were basically synonymous with cell phones.
But, this was actually a massive disadvantage.
They key point to note is that Nokia was synonymous
with cell phones, not smart phones.
So, if anything, Nokia needed to work extra
hard to shift away from this association with
brick phones, but they ended up doing the
exact opposite as they let this association
drive customers to Samsung and Apple.
So, to sum things up, Nokia was overconfident
while they dropped the ball on software, hardware,
and branding.
But, just as things were looking worse than
ever in the early 2010s, they would see a
glimmer of hope from Microsoft.
MICROSOFT DROPS THE BALL:
You see, it wasn’t just Nokia that had missed
out on the smartphone revolution.
Someone else that had missed out and was desperate
to make their way back in was Microsoft.
As such, these two would decide to join forces
and take on the smartphone industry together.
The first step in this partnership was letting
Stephen Elop, a Microsoft executive take the
reigns on Nokia.
In late 2010, Elop would join Nokia as their
first non Finnish CEO and just a couple of
months later, he would ink a deal with Microsoft
to become their primary smartphone partner.
Elop justified this gamble as a hail mary
that Nokia had to do to survive but really,
he had just signed their own death sentence.
The problem with the Microsoft partnership
was that it solved absolutely none of Nokia’s
fundamental issues.
Take software for example.
Windows Mobile wasn’t a revolutionary OS
that was designed from the ground up for touch
screen handheld devices like Android or iOS
was.
Windows Mobile was really just a janky touch
screen version of Windows.
As such, developer support was abysmal meaning
that Nokia made almost no progress on the
software side of things.
In fact, you could even argue that they made
negative progress as they would start supporting
Bing and Bing Maps.
As for the hardware side of things, this was
still largely up to Nokia because Microsoft
was mainly just a software partner.
And as such, Nokia would continue to drop
the ball when it came to hardware.
The Lumia 630 for example only had 512 MB
of ram, no 4G, no flash, no selfie cam, and
a 480p resolution screen.
And Nokia had the audacity to launch this
in mid 2014 just before the launch of the
iPhone 6.
It’s really no wonder why things didn’t
work out.
But despite this, their combined overconfidence
was higher than ever as Microsoft was even
more overconfident than Nokia.
In fact, they would even stage a fake funeral
for Apple.
Yeah, that aged really well.
The one thing that I would say Nokia actually
did improve upon was branding.
The brand Lumia was far better than just labeling
their phones the 603 or the 808, but given
that nothing else improved, neither did Nokia’s
position.
Under Elop’s leadership, Nokia’s stock
price crashed 62%, their mobile phone market
share haved, their smartphone market share
fell from 33% to 3%, and the company lost
€4.9 billion.
To make things worse, it seems that Elop was
more concerned about saving himself instead
of saving the company.
Instead of pivoting to Android or even just
expanding to Android, Elop would use the last
leverage that Nokia had over Microsoft to
force them into an acquisition.
Microsoft, who’s options where to either
give up on the phone market right then and
there or spend $7.2 billion and have one last
chance would choose the latter.
Honestly, this was a really smart play by
Elop for himself as he would return to Microsoft
as an executive after dropping the ball completely
with Nokia.
But, the same could not be said about Nokia.
Just because Nokia had forced Microsoft to
take the plunge didn’t mean that Microsoft
suddenly had a beter strategy.
In fact, remember the Lumia 630 that they
launched right before the iPhone 6, well,
that was after Microsoft took over.
Yeah, I don’t think you’d be surprised
to hear that after such failures, Microsoft
would just end up neglecting the phone business
for a few years before shutting it down completely.
NOKIA RESURRECTS:
The silver lining about all of this was that
Microsoft didn’t buyout the entirety of
Nokia.
If they had, the entire brand would probably
be gone by today.
Luckily for Nokia, they only bought out the
phone portion of their business but with that
being said, this was their main business,
so Nokia was left in a pretty bad situation.
All they had left was their network business
but looking back, this may have actually been
a blessing in disguise.
You see, selling off their phone business
forced them to figure out a way to survive
without their hero product and that’s exactly
what they did.
They poured all of their resources into revamping
their network business and fixing all their
previous mistakes.
For example, remember how they were previously
neglecting 4G?
Well, Nokia would become the first to demonstrate
a 5G ready network in 2016.
They also stopped relying so heavily on the
Nokia brand because well enterprise customers
care way more about value, pricing, and results
over branding.
And as for their overconfidence, this was
naturally completely gone as they were literally
fighting for survival.
None of these moves returned Nokia to their
former heights but it did salvage the business.
By 2017, Nokia would return to the Fortune
500 as they solidified their position as the
world’s 3rd largest telecommunications equipment
manufacturer, only beaten out by Huawei and
Ericsson.
And this recovery would be just in time for
Nokia to return to the phone business.
You see, after Microsoft gave up on the phone
business, they would sell of the remaining
parts of Nokia for $350 million.
This consisted of two parts.
The first was the brand rights to Nokia which
were sold to a couple of Nokia executives
who created a new company called HMD Global.
The second was the manufacturing and distribution
side of Nokia which were sold to Foxconn.
Shortly after, HMD Global and Foxconn would
enter into an agreement to bring Nokia back
to the phone market.
But this time, Nokia didn’t make the same
mistake of partnering with Microsoft.
Instead, they would partner with Google and
bring the first Nokia Android to market in
early 2017.
To be honest, given how late they were to
the market, it’s unlikely that Nokia will
ever challenge the likes of Apple or Samsung
and return to their former glory.
But, that isn’t to say that they can’t
have a smaller profitable business selling
affordable smartphones which is exactly what
they’ve done.
In Q3 of 2021, for example, they were able
to ship almost 3 million smartphones.
So, on an annual basis, they’re selling
about 10 million smartphones which again is
only a tenth of what they used to sell but
considering the disaster they went through
with Microsoft, this itself is quite impressive.
So going back to the question of the day:
How is Nokia even still around?
Well, after getting their butt kicked by Apple,
Samsung, and Google, and losing their business
to Microsoft, Nokia returned to business world
as a humbled company.
Instead of trying to recapture what they once
had, they decided to focus on salvaging what
they still had by focusing on networking equipment.
And when Microsoft gave up on Nokia, some
of Nokia’s executives decided to revitalize
the brand and become a small but successful
player in the modern smartphone world instead
of not being a player at all.
And that’s how Nokia managed to stick around.
This story is completely different from Microsoft's
perspective.
If you’d like to hear their side of it,
check out this video.